merci dernière question inscrite à
l'ordre du jour la question numéro 244
de Madame Joë garot Mame à monsieur le
ministre du Travail de l'Emploi de la
Formation Professionnelle et du dialogue
social merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre je souhaiterais
vous interroger sur l'accès à
l'assurance chômage des Français ayant
travaillé dans un autre pays de l'Union
européenne selon les derniers chiffres
de l'INC publié jeudi dernier au 4e
trimestre 2012 10,2 % de la population
active était au chômage en France
métropolite
un tel niveau n'avait pas été atteint
depuis le printemps 99 même durant la
crise des années 2008-2009 le taux de
chômage n'avait pas franchi ce seuil les
jeunes sont les plus touchés plus d'un
quart d'entre eux 25,7 % sont
aujourd'hui au chômage d'après un
sondage de loi Tifa publié il y a 2
semaines 27 % des jeunes diplômés
cherchant un travail pensent que leur
avenir professionnel se situe à
l'étranger plutôt qu'en France ils ne
partent bien souvent pas avec des
contrats myifiques mais plutôt en VI ou
en contrat local dans ce contexte nous
sommes face à deux impératif d'une part
favoriser la mobilité professionnelle en
particulier des jeunes et d'autre part
assurer un filet social minimal à ces
professionnels s'ils reviennent en
France après avoir perdu leur emploi à
l'étranger ces deux objectifs sont bien
évidemment lié puisqu'il est plus facile
de partir lorsque l'on sait qu'une
sécurité minimale est assurée au retour
faciliter la mobilité professionnelle
est l'un des objectifs de l'Union
européenne le principe de la libre
circulation des personnes et de la non
discrimination du fait de la nationalité
autorise un individu à conserver ses
droits aux allocations de chômage à
quiis dans un pays de l'Espace
économique européen et à les faire
valoir dans un autre pays des règlements
communautaires 883 2004 9872009 vise à
concrétiser ses droits en améliorant la
coordination des systèmes d'assurance
chômage la législation européenne
dispose ainsi que les périodes
d'activité accomplies dans un autre état
de l'Espace économique européen doivent
être prises en compte par l'État de
résidence pour le calcul des périodes
d'emploi ouvrant le droit à l'octroit de
prestation pourtant un Français rentrant
en France après avoir travaillé dans un
autre état de l'Espace économique
européen ou en Suisse et y ayant donc
cotisé à l'assur en chômage semble ne
pouvoir prétendre à une allocation
chômage qu'à condition de P pouir
justifier d'une activité minimale
salariée sur le sol français postérieure
à l'activité exercé à l'étranger faute
de remplir cette exigence le demandeur
d'emploi ne peut bénéficier sous
condition que d'une allocation
forfaitaire l'allocation temporaire
d'attente seuls les travailleurs
frontaliers bénéficient de dispositions
particulières permettant de déroger à
cette règle je j'aimerais que vous me
disiez monsieur le ministre si cette
exigence française de justifi ication
est bien conforme au droit européens par
ailleurs le calcul du montant de
laallocation versé par paôul emploi est
établi sur la base des seulle
rémunération perçu en France après le
retour d'expatriation dans l'espace
économique européen de ce fait les
rémunérations perçues au titre d'une
activité exercée dans un autre état de
l'Espace économique européen ne sont
prises en compte que pour déterminer la
durée des droits loocation chômage et
non pour le calcul de son mentant ce qui
peut être fortement pénalisant pour les
personnes de retour d'expatriation ne
serait-il pas envisageable de modifier
cette disposition afin de favoriser la
réinsertion en France des personnes
ayant travaillé ailleurs en Europe et
d'encourager ainsi nos chercheurs
d'emploi tenter leur chance ailleurs
dans l'Union européenne en sachant
qu'ils bénéficieront d'un filet de
sécurité à leur retour enfin je voudrais
attirer votre attention sur la nécessité
d'une meilleure information des
travailleurs quant aux conséquences
d'une expatriation sur leurs droits en
matière de chômage salarié ayant
travaillé en contrat local dans un autre
pays européen ne pourra bénéficier d'une
indemnité chômage en France que si
l'arrêt de son contrat obéit à certains
critères valables d'un pays à l'autre
variable pardon d'un pays à l'autre et
s'il respecte un certain nombre de
procédures monsieur le ministre le
gouvernement pourrait-il prendre des
mesures pour améliorer l'information des
salariés je vous remercie merci Monsieur
le
Ministre bien madame la sénatrice gar
Mame les règles communautaires de
coordination de sécurité sociale
permettent de garantir et de faciliter
cet exercice de libre
circulation des travailleurs salariés
même si votre question montre qu'il y a
encore des améliorations à apporter et
nous en sommes tous convaincus ainsi
l'article 51 du traité de Rome prévoit
les mesures nécessaires pour faciliter
la libre circulation des travailleurs en
en instituant notamment pour l'ouverture
le calcul et le maintien des droits
prestations un système de totalisation
des périodes prises en considération par
les différentes législations nationales
la mise en œuvre du principe de
totalisation est alors subordonnée à la
condition que l'intéressé est accompli
en dernier lieu soit des périodes
d'assurance soit des périodes d'emploi
dans l'état où les prestations sont
sollicitées c'est une application d'un
règlement en cons pour pouvoir prétendre
aux allocations du régime d'assurant
chômage français l'intéressé doit avant
de s'inscrire comme demandeur d'emploi
en France avoir retravailler en France
le règlement numéro 883 200004 modifié
et son règlement d'application 9872009
ont par ailleurs instauré depuis le 1er
mai 2010 de nouvelles règles relatives à
la coordination des systèmes de sécurité
sociale des États-membres s'agissant
plus particulier ement des règles
relatives à l'assurance chômage l'une
des principales modifications apportées
par ces nouveaux règlements concerne la
suppression d'un salaire d'équivalence
pour les personnes ayant travaillé moins
de 4 semaines à leur retour en France
c'est sur la base de ce salaire
déterminé en référence au salaire versé
par un emploi équivalent en France par
la Direction régionale des entreprises
la concurrence la consommation du
travail et de l'emploi que le montant de
l'allocation chômage était auparavant
calculé toujours depuis depuis le 1er
mai 2010 en application des dispositions
un article 62 du règlement 883 2004 le
calcul de l'allocation au chômage est
effectué directement par Pôle emploi sur
la base des seules rémunérations perçu
par l'intéressé au titre de la dernière
activité salariée qu'il a exercé sous la
législation de l'État où les prestations
sont sollicités les rémunérations
perçues au titre d'une activité exercée
dans un autre état membres de l'Union
européenne ne sont pas pris en compte
pour le calcul de l'allocation par
ailleurs pour déterminer la durée
d'indemnisation pour l'emploi prend en
compte la durée d'affiliation
correspondant aux périodes de travail
accompli dans l'État membre de l'Union
européenne via un formulaire
communautaire ce document est délivré
sur demande par l'institution compétente
de l'État dans lequel le travail a été
accompli dès lors madame la sénatrice
c'est bien la réglementation européenne
qui fixe les principes de coordination
des rgime d'assurance permettant de
prendre en compte les périodes
d'activité accomplies dans un autre État
membre c'est bien la réglementation
européenne enfin cette dernière
réglementation européenne en supprimant
c'est une bonne chose l'obligation pour
les directes d'établir un salaire
d'équivalence a néanmoins permis la
simplification des procédures et en
conséquence la réduction des délais de
traitement bref il y a eu du mieux mais
il y en a sans doute encore attendre
dans les années qui viennent et je sais
que la sénatrice représentant les
Français d'étrangers que vous êtes sera
attentif à ces améliorations que vous
appelez légitimement de vos
vœux merci Monsieur le Ministre madame
gar Mame oui je voudrais vous remercier
Monsieur le Ministre pour ces précisions
il y a effectivement beaucoup
d'amélioration à apporter c'est
indispensable pour les Français de
l'étranger pour qui ce sujet est
essentiel l'emploi est essentiel en
crise économique en période de crise
économique aigu et bien évidem la notion
d'information aussi est importante parce
que beaucoup de nos compatriotes
ignorent ces règles quand ils partent à
l'étranger et si vous pouviez monsieur
le ministre suggérer au gouvernement de
prendre des mesures d'information sur
ces questions-l dans un contexte où je
le rappelais dans ma question de plus en
plus de jeunes partent à l'étranger à la
recherche d'un premier emploi ce serait
là faire une œuvre très utile et je vous
en remercie dès après
merci ma chère collègue nous en avons
donc terminé avec la séance des
questions orales je vais donc suspendre
la séance elle sera reprise à 14h30 pour
leséloges funèbre de Monsieur René
Vestri qui a été sénateur des Alpes
Maritimes la séance est
suspendu